[Musik]
die orientalische stab über den usb
kister
sie gehört zu den bekanntesten
sehenswürdigkeiten des landes
die moscheen die mit riesen und
minarette zeigen deutlich welchen
reichtum die seidenstraße in die länder
zentralasiens gebracht hat
[Musik]
die gut erhaltenen innenstädte gehören
zum weltkulturerbe und man zeigt uns
dieser gerne
problematisches hätten wir hingegen
nicht sehen sollen die usbekischen
behörden haben deshalb versucht und
stets an einer kurzen leine zu halten
[Musik]
in unseren letzten folgen sind wer von
venedig über die türkei und den kaukasus
gereist wir haben das kaspische meer
gequert und waren in kasachstan
unterwegs von beinahe aus sind ja zur
östlichen grenze gefahren dann nach
lukas den hauptort der usbekischen
region karl pakistan die stadt lukas
beherbergt einen ganz besonderen schatz
ein museum mit kunstwerken welcher unter
stalin als unangebrachte bürger kunst
geächtet war und sie marini cabanas
araber kämpft mit leidenschaft um den
erhalt dieses schatzes ihr museum zeige
was die sowjetregierung damals vor den
eigenen bürgern zu verstecken versucht
habe sagt die kuratorin
sowohl die lokale volkskultur wie auch
die damalige am organe russland habe man
unterdrückt nur hier an diesem
abgelegenen ort mitten in der wüste xp
distanz gelang es ermutigen mann igor
sawicki die geächteten bilder und
gegenstände zu sammeln
stalin hat er damals lokale sitten und
traditionen unterdrückt wie etwa das
bier sender caracol packen und auch eine
art jeansstoff aus der region ist in
vergessenheit geraten
stoff aus dem einstigen kahn hat
pakistans sehe ich das richtig
ja sicher diese baumwollstoffe hier sind
ähnlich gemacht wie der moderne denim
stoff aus dem die amerikaner vor 150
jahren blue jeans zu fertigen begannen
die caracalla packen kann ok die gleiche
technologie schon drei jahrhunderte
früher aus diesen stoffen machte man vor
allem hochzeits kostüme welche die
familien clans von einer generation zur
nächsten weiterreichen
rom
in diesen vitrinen ehrt das museum seine
begründung
1915 geboren hat der junge kunst student
und maler sawicki den künstlerischen
wert jener werke erkannt welche das
regime seinerzeit bekämpfte einem
studienaufenthalt in das big ist da hat
er sich entschlossen solche werke
versteck wegen zusammen und hier im
süden der einstigen sowjetunion in
sicherheit zu bringen
1966 aber die zeiten haben sich geändert
durfte er das museum eröffnen
gewissermaßen als kulturpolitischer
dissident ist des ego sawicki gelungen
sein mission gegen manchen behördlichen
widerstand durchzusetzen wäre 10.000
bilder hat er so gesammelt er sammelte
was für das damalige sowjetische
kunstverständnis völlig unangebracht war
im bild der gewinner wird der sieger
eines boxkampfes nicht etwa im triumph
gezeigt sondern deprimiert von hinten
mit auf den verlierer des kampfes
gerichtetem blick
die toleranz gegenüber allem was nicht
dem damals gepflegten sozialistischen
realismus entsprach war minimal
auch dieses werk passte denn kultur
beharrten nicht fordern eine moderne
schulterfrei gekleidete muslimin mit
ihrem mann
und dahinter ein traditioneller
islamischer husbäke von 1 mit zwei
frauen deren köpfe verlegt zugeschmiert
sind
[Musik]
dann führt mich die kuratorin zu einem
protest will aus den frühen siebziger
jahren zu einem werk des moskauer
künstler hrubesch ging es zeigt wie
bulldozer auf geheiß des kgb eine
unbewilligte ausstellung unliebsamer mal
und niederwalzen die geschichte hat sich
tatsächlich zugetragen und die gosse de
ski hat einige solcher protest
kunstwerke vor der vernichtung retten
können
[Musik]
angenommen es würde hier ein brand wüten
und sie könnten 1 nur eins der welt
retten welches würden sie sich
entscheiden
das möchte ich mir lieber nicht
vorstellen eine schreckliche vorstellung
welches bild würden schwierig zu sagen
welches das wertvollste ist es wäre sehr
schwierig die richtige wahl zu treffen
ich würde wahrscheinlich im museum
bleiben weil ich mir nie im leben
verzeihen könnte nicht dieses oder jenes
gerettet zu haben
alle diese bilder sind doch teil unseres
lebens die sind wir unsere kinder wie
nur könnte man ein einzelnes retten und
die anderen ihrem schicksal überlassen
ich glaube es wäre in diesem fall besser
selbst auch im museum zu bleiben um zu
sterben ja zusammen mit den bildern zum
abschied zeigt und die leidenschaftliche
museumsdirektorin noch ein spezielles
der werde
der maler volkov hat sich oft mit den
karawanen befasst mit der dynamik des
ostens mit bewegung
es zeigt usbekistan als zentrum der
handelswege die karawane symbolisiert
die seidenstraße steht für den austausch
für den handel
auch für den dialog zwischen
philosophieren und kulturen
[Musik]
von lukas ausfahren wir südostwärts
immer weitere das berühmte diva in die
legendäre stadt buchen
auf schlechter straße durch die staubige
steppe
[Musik]
bis die landschaft grüner wert und wir
hatten am oder erklären der hier noch
wasser führt ein paar hundert kilometer
unterhalb dieser brücke aber in der
steppe vollständig versickern gehabt
eigentlich ist usbekistan bekannt der
seine baumwollfeldern
doch es wäre doch reis angepflanzt usb
kische städte werden mit wasser aus dem
fluss so intensive ressort dass hier
auch preis wächst
[Musik]
am nächsten tag staunen wir wie das
wasser des amu darya sprite mandant
durch die städte fließt
an diesem langen abschnitt der
usbekischen fernverkehrsstraße wird seit
jahren gewerkelt kilometer weit nur
provisorien und baustellen
wir kommen nur mit einer
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit von etwa 25
kilometern pro stunde vom fleck
seidenstraße wird so für uns zur
holprigen leiden straße
endlich erreichen wir buchara buchara
gehört zusammen mit sammer kann zu den
bekanntesten usbekischen städten die mit
prächtigsten moscheen erhalten und mit
riesenaufwand
[Musik]
und mit traditionellem kunsthandwerk
liberalen bei gleich für den
stadtzentrum von buchwert von hand
gemachte und verzierte keramik angeboten
gibt ihnen
in einem vorort von buch habel suchen
wir das appelliert er töpfer
familiennachzug abdullah abdullah führt
in betrieben der sechsten generation der
familienbetrieb ist auch in der
sowjetischen zeit nie verstaatlicht
worden
und weil das kunsthandwerkern wichtiger
motor der usbekischen tourismusindustrie
sei werde der betrieb heute vom staat
begünstigt
seit etwa 17 jahren müssen wir keine
einkommenssteuer bezahlen
der staat will damit der handwerkskunst
neuen schub verleihen
das handwerk ist für usbekistan von
besonderer bedeutung
erstens geht es darum die tradition
wiederzubeleben
denn sie ist die geschichte unseres
landes zweitens schaffen wir
arbeitsplätze und drittens solche
werkstätten dienen auch der entwicklung
unserer jugend während der schul für
ihren arbeiten hier alle mit auch die
kinder von verwandten die tonerde die
für das tab von verwendet wird stammt
aus der region und auch die farben
werden auf herkömmliche weise direkt der
natur ab gewonnen
die musterung native sie sind von
generation zu generation weitergereicht
worden
[Musik]
das sind kacheln welche hier in der
region die fassaden von moscheen von mit
riesen und minaretten zieren hergestellt
nach einem alten rezept
die kacheln müssen höchsten ansprüchen
genügen
sie müssen große temperaturschwankungen
aushalten hitze schnee reden
die glasur sorgt dafür dass durch die
ritzen der zusammengefügten kacheln kein
wasser trinkt so werden die kacheln
aneinandergefügt wenn die glasur gut
abdichtet kann kein wasser mehr
durchbringen
es gibt viele geheimnisse wie man solche
kacheln fertigt dann wär abdullah etwas
weniger perms unsere ton schalen
durchlaufen einen umfangreichen prozess
die erste klausur die zweite zweimal
werden die schalen gebrannt und hier
kommt dann noch eine letzte kleine nicht
unwichtige etappe der verkauf das ist
ein kleiner scherz aber ohne geschäft
kam alles zum stillstand
hier an diesen fassaden bucherer sind
diese hell und dunkel blauen kacheln zu
sehen die abdullah nach zu leihen
nach alter tradition er stellt sein
atelier ist auch an der renovation
dieser historischen gebäude beteiligt
das zentrum der stadt ist von einer
ruhigen ja von einer etwas musealen
atmosphäre geprägt
es ist aber auch ein pilgerort
doch von einem muslimischen
fundamentalismus ist hier kaum was zu
spüren
die rund 27 millionen usbekin und
usbeken leben einen auffallend moderaten
islam
und hier hier wird der kühle innenhof
einer einstigen koranschule für eine
touristenattraktion zweckentfremdet
dass der plot ist eine folkloristisch
angehauchte modeschau kombiniert mit
volkstänzen und live begleitet von einer
lokalen musikergruppe
[Musik]
das besondere an diesem spektakel
ersetzt während der wirtschaftskrise in
der 90er jahren als selbsthilfeprojekt
einer engagierten frauen gruppe
entstanden unter der leitung von irina
scharipowa studentinnen präsentieren
kleider und stoffe welche von etwa drei
dutzend frauen des unternehmens
geschneidert und am rand der vorführung
zum kauf angeboten werden meine lieben
bewegt durch stolz wie schwäne
wir sind eine familie und alles frauen
nur zwei männer sind unter uns die
reparieren unsere nähmaschinen jede von
uns hat ihr eigenes schicksal
es sind junge unverheiratete unter uns
aber auch ältere die schon erwachsene
kinder haben und alle arbeiten hier ihr
tägliches überleben was wir
erwirtschaften gehört uns und wir sind
40 die von diesem projekt leben das der
aprimo die ist teil des
touristenprogramm sind bucherer
[Musik]
diesen fabelhaften seidenstoffen werden
wir auch wieder china begegnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von bucher reisen wir immer weiter
ostwärts und nächstes ziel bekannt
auf dem registan platz ziehen uns die
wohl berühmtesten fassaden usb-stick
koranschulen in ihren bann
man kann sich hier war los um die eigene
achse drehen und in eine beliebige
richtung blicken wo auch immer man
hinschaut es ist überwältigend
gerne wären wir noch ein wenig hier
geblieben
doch wir haben einen reiseplan und der
rest der welt mit dem usbekischen
behörden abgesprochen
das ist unsere reiseleiterin sie
begleitet und wird dabei aber selbst von
der behörden streng überwacht
denn so ihr auftrag wir wollen ins beeck
ist da nur das zu sehen bekommen was
ihnen genehm ist
nur wenige kilometer von orientalischen
zentrum sommer ganz entfernt am bahnhof
die neue die hightech welt usbekistans
der usbekische schnell verkehrszug rossi
ab der luxuszug er ausschließlich
zwischen sommer kommt und der
usbekischen hauptstadt taschkent
trennen im zug wird unsere reiseleiterin
nervös
ich bleibe die meiste zeit auf dem
reservierten platz setzen
als ich mal versuche auf einen anderen
sessel zu wechseln taucht sofort ein
bewacher auf und da kündigt sich nach
meinem verbleib fragt sie
wir werden strenger überwacht als
hippies lang gelernt hatten
die 350 kilometer von samarkand nach
taschkent legen wir in diesem
komfortablen hochgeschwindigkeitszug im
nu zurück in diesem palast führt
präsident islam karimov seit über 20
jahren ein äußerst strenges regime her
und seinem familien-clan beherrschen das
land auf uns wirkt das regierungszentrum
steif und steril
während des vielen einwohnern der
hauptstadt dann wasser fehlt sprudelt es
hier demonstrativ vor den gebäuden der
machen
zwar sind wir mit vielen verschiedenen
bewilligungen ausgerichtet doch alle 50
meter steht ein polizist der sich nicht
vorwerfen lassen will
er habe uns nicht ausreichend
kontrolliert
[Musik]
karimov ist ein präsident der sich
hinter seinem prunkwagen abschottet
um die politischen rechte ist es in
usbekistan schlecht bestellt das ist
bekannt hier starten einem der wenigen
kritischen journalisten in taschkent
einen diskreten besuch ab wie erlebt er
sein land alexej iwanowitsch wurmt in
einer etwas heruntergekommenen wohnung
er arbeitet von hier aus für
verschiedene internet agenturen
wir haben probleme mit den
menschenrechten aber auch mit dem recht
auf eigentum
ein beispiel sie eröffneten geschäft
investieren 30.000 dollar und das
geschäft läuft kommt schon morgen können
beamte vorbei kommen und sagen fertig
hier wird eine tankstelle gebaut
es ist dann völlig nutzlos zu
diskutieren zur verstärkung kommt die
polizei und wer sich der staatsmacht
entgegenstellt gegen den wird ein
strafverfahren eröffnet
mit solchen methoden sind allein im
letzten jahr im land etwa 1000 geschäfte
geschlossen
keiner der geschäftsleute hat je eine
kompensation
die leute werden einfach enteignet sich
nicht entmutigen lassen er erläutert
mehr wie arm viele usbeken nach wie vor
dran sind in einem bereich aber habe der
autoritäre präsident zumindest
sinnvolles getan meint er
er hat es in den letzten 20 jahren nicht
zugelassen dass sich usbekistan in ein
zweites afghanistan verwandelt hat er
hat die islamisten stark eingeschränkt
in den 90er jahren wurden hier mit
unterstützung aus saudi arabien pakistan
und anderer länder islamistische werte
geweckt karimov hat dem einhalt geboten
das zweite positive was man zu karimov
erwähnen kann ist kein wilder
nationalist
danach vor allem karimov hat sich die
macht mit zahlreichen tricks gesichert
das ist der auftakt zu einer usbekischen
hochzeit am ende unseres reiseprogramms
und das ist nur alleva vertreterin der
stiftung fand forum von der wir
eingeladen worden
wir sind im januar in der nähe von
taschkent wir werden zeuge wie nicht nur
eines sondern gleich neun paare
verheiratet werden dank einer stiftung
der präsidententochter gulnara karimowa
die traditionellen hochzeitskleider
ausstellen gehören der vergangenheit an
paare aus waisenheimen oder familien mit
niedrigem einkommen erhalten ein fest
dass sie sich sonst nicht leisten
könnten sagt die stiftung eine stiftung
die den präsidenten quellen
dem vernehmen nach vor allem als große
internationale geldanlage dient in
usbekistan ist die spannung groß
zwischen westlicher modernität und
orientalischer tradition und es braucht
durchaus mut darüber zu reden
die junge vertreterin der stiftung wagt
es über die doppelten standards im lande
zu sprechen
kann man nicht sehr lang also in den
denken sie jetzt ihr verhältnis zu sein
kann man nichts
freund und freundlichen freundin
zusammenleben oder
man ist so lange sein
aber
gleichzeitig
möchten wir alle also
und besser kennenzulernen
das ist noch ein standard wir möchten
aber wir können ist
nun gilt es ernst 18 gestiftete ringe
müssen an 18 jungfräuliche hände
gesteckt werden welche braut zu welchem
bräutigam gehört ist klar welche ringe
für welche finger bestimmt sind haben
die organisatoren zwar bestehen aber
nicht so wirklich im griff
die paare jedenfalls lassen sich nicht
aus der ruhe bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der schönste moment am schönsten tag im
leben muss sich noch gedulden
traute zweisamkeit hat keine chance in
folge füllten sal
die jungen benefiz brautleute spielen
ihre statistenrolle für die kameras und
mikrofone des stiftungseigenen
fernsehkanals der dem ganzen land zeigen
wird wie großzügig die armen untertanen
von der präsidialen stiftung unterstützt
werden tausend arme parabel die stiftung
verheiraten verspricht das plakat im
hintergrund und wie stellt sich
stiftungsvertreter in nohra ihre eigene
hochzeit vor
warum
das eines neuen tag ist
mein tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vor allem einer also ich möchte allein
in meinem tag sein
was die paare über ihren tag denken
fragen wir nicht erstens dürfen wir das
nicht und zweitens einer geschenkten
hochzeit schaut man nicht ins füllhorn
[Applaus]
auch über die gerade geschnittenen
gnaden des dorfes breitet die stiftung
an diesem festtag ihren segen haus die
kleinen prinzen erhalten fahrräder
spielzeug und geschenke
auf unserer reise durch usbekistan haben
wir oft eine inszenierung aufgetischt
bekommen und das wirkte dann immer etwas
gezwungen zum schluss erleben wir
endlich bei diesen jungen leuten so
etwas wie ungezwungene und echte
lebensfreude der präsidententochter
zeitung
[Musik]
wir verlassen muss weg ist und reisen
zuerst in den süden kirgistans nach osch
die stadt liegt am rande des fruchtbaren
fergana tal sind grenznähe zu usbekistan
die stadt groß war immer schon ein
schnittpunkt der handelswege und ist es
auch heute noch
hier mischen sich verschiedenste
volksgruppen
der riesige markt ist ein oder
wichtigsten in zentralasien
ich kaufe getrocknete aprikosen von
denen es hier mindestens ein halbes
dutzend sorten gibt einer der wegner
kroos kommt aus tadschikistan und von
dort dienen die früchte oft nur als
tarnung für ein weit wertvolleres gut
für drogen
der fluss brunch teil der rund 1300
kilometer langen grenze zwischen dem
nördlichen afghanistan und tadschikistan
[Musik]
jedes afghanische dorf ein potenzielles
versteck für heroin und haschisch
die afghanischen grenztruppen scheint
das wenig zu kümmern
[Musik]
der tadschikische polizeioberst mac
mettenheim aufnimmt uns mit obwohl hier
ausländer eigentlich eine
sondergenehmigung des geheimdienstes
bräuchten hier in tadschikistan will man
verhindern dass die drogen aus
afghanistan über die grenze kommen
zumindest offiziell
der kampf gegen den drogenschmuggel in
diesem riesen gebiet ist fast chancenlos
woher kommt das rauschgift natürlich aus
afghanistan
alle drogen kommen aus afghanistan
schauen sie sich doch den fluss an
in 23 minuten ist er überquert dafür
reicht ein kleines gummiboot und schon
sind die drogen auf unserem territorium
die schmuggler machen das meistens
nachts tagsüber es ihnen natürlich zu
gefährlich
auch in den tadschikischen grenzdörfern
ist die versuchung groß beim
drogenhandel mitzumachen
die menschen in tadschikistan sind die
ärmsten in der ganzen ehemaligen
sowjetunion mit granatäpfeln und anderen
landwirtschaftsprodukten lässt sich kaum
etwas verdienen
da versucht manch einer drogen zu
schmuggeln
vor kurzem haben wir hier ganz in der
nähe dieser brücke und 30 kilogramm
drogen aufgespürt
hier unter dieser brücke war die
schmuggler haben vom richter 14 bis 18
jahre gefängnis erhalten
den drakonischen strafen zum trotz rund
250 kilogramm heroin und opium werden
jeden tag über die grenze nach
tadschikistan geschmuggelt
in der hauptstadt duschanbe ist
zwischenstation für die großen mengen
rauschgift
polizeirazzien und zufalls kontrollen
sind an die einzige möglichkeit drogen
aufzuspüren
wie streng die als hoch korrupt
geltenden polizisten dabei vorgehen
lässt sich schwer sagen
sie zumindest sind unbestechlich arena
ein spanien und kollege pablo sind
ausgebildete drogen schnüffler sie haben
eine äußerst feine nase für kleinste
rauschgift spuren über drogenhunde
verfügt hat gestern erst seit wenigen
jahren sie drüben viel zum erfolg der
fahndung bei erzählt man uns allerdings
gibt es auch grenzen
zum beispiel wenn sie statt teekannen
große zementsäcke beschnuppern müssen
das hält ihr näschen nicht lange aus bei
unserem besuch gab es heute keinen
drogenfund hier sollte es dann aber
besser aussehen
die drogenkontrolle agentur die direkt
dem tadschikischen präsidenten
untersteht chef laborant die lüdia
klitschko war lässt uns einen blick auf
die frische beute werfen die
drogenfahnder in der nacht an
verschiedenen orten aufgespürt hatten
über 50 kilogramm haschisch und rund ein
kilogramm heroin
jetzt suchen die ermittler spuren und
die nötigen beweise gegen die
drogenschmuggler sammeln zu können
das haschisch ist noch in der für
afghanistan typischen verpackung die es
vor feuchtigkeit und nässe schützt es
wurde nahe der grenze beschlagnahmt ein
kilogramm heroin stammt von einer
untersuchung am flughafen
offensichtlich war der schmuggler der
flughafenkontrolle aufgefallen weil der
erwachsenen windeln trug er noch eine
probe des heroins ein kilogramm steckte
er sich in die pampers kurz vor dem
abflug wurde er verhaftet
schauen sie sich das an was denken sie
was das ist
das ist heroin ein einheimischer
schlaumeier hat es mit aktivkohle in
einen plastik ähnlichen stoff
verarbeitet und damit die innen
verstärkungen seines koffers ausgefällt
und hier eine sammlung von
trockenfrüchten und nüssen hier zum
beispiel haben wir echte mandeln und
hier eine mit heroin gefällt wenn man
die nüsse ins heiße wasser taucht kann
man ihr die haut abziehen
die drogenproduzenten formen dann aus
heroin mandl ähnliche stücke und kleben
die haut drauf mit dem pistazien tun sie
das selbe
so wird heroin kiloweise geschmuggelt
in tadschikistan ist oft viel mehr
schein als sein
die stadt mit den vielen luxusautos
scheint reicher als es die statistik
aussagt
die internationale kritik die korrupte
tadschikische elite verdiene selber
kräftig mit am drogen transfer das
allerheiligste der drogen jeder das
beschlagnahmte heroin und haschisch alle
paar monate wird die ware verbrannt
heißt es hier ist vor allem heroin
verpackt hier ein afghanisches
qualitätslabel zementsäcke vermischt mit
heroin das was die spürhunde am
wenigsten geben hier hinten sind vor
allem cannabis produkte gelagert
wir sind also drogen im wert von ein
paar millionen für mich
es bleiben mehr fragen als antworten
tatsache ist die türkischen behörden
beschlagnahmen trotz massiver
internationaler hilfe keine zehn prozent
der drogen die tatsächlich durchs land
transportiert werden
richtung russland und europa
die einfachen menschen in den dörfern am
rand der drogen route haben davon nichts
jeder zweite einwohner des landes muss
mit weniger als 2 franken pro tag
auskommen
das ifh support fünf jahre als
gastarbeiter in russland gearbeitet und
geld heimgeschickt so wie es der
grossteil seiner landsleute tut jobs in
russland sind die andere wichtige
geldquelle filter registan nebst dem
drogengeschäft von dem sei er verschont
geblieben sagt uns massiv cars of nine
damit hatte ich nie zu tun wozu auch das
ist ein kriminelles und gefährliches
geschäft wir sind hier glücklich mit dem
was wir haben
der handel mit drogen auch heute noch
eine der dunklen seiten der seidenstraße
von unserem abstecher nach tadschikistan
kehren wir zurück nach osch früher
stellten die usbeken hier fast die
hälfte ein bogen doch im juni 2010
brachen wille der pogrome aus gegen die
usb können dass stadt osch
und so ist seit dem sommer 2010 das
verhältnis zwischen den kassen und den
usbeken in der stadt osch zerrüttet
viele häuser liegen in schutt und asche
die stadt osch ist ein ethnischer
flickenteppich ab drauf tapies office
katar
er lebt in einem der usbeken viertel der
stab und hat die reise vom sommer 2010
als zeuge mit dem damals erzählte hätten
die randalierenden kehrten auch sein
haus in brand gesteckt
ich bin zum ob rausgegangen und habe
gesagt ihr seht doch dass mein dach mit
dem der usbekischen nachbarn verbunden
ist wenn er sein dach in brand steckt
brennt auch mainz einer der jungen
krisen hat an den anderen gesagt
er bittet uns wie ein vater fast dieses
haus nicht an
ich habe dann gesagt ich bin allein kann
man haus nicht löschen
schließlich haben sie eingelenkt und
mein haus verschont
für seine usbekischen nachbarn hat der
tat aber nichts ausrichten können nur
für sich selbst
überall im quartier sind die spuren der
zerstörung zu sehen
tausende usbeken sind damals geflüchtet
jetzt wird vorsichtig versucht die
quartiere wieder aufzubauen
hier stand einst aus der usbeken familie
sei der kauf ein bisschen habe sich die
situation für sich verbessert aber
wirklich nur ein bisschen
wir können unser areal nicht
abschließend es gibt kein tor mehr
man hat uns auch schon gestohlen
alles ist offen wir können
rechtsschützen zeit zum teil
hoffnungslos die meisten usbekin und
usbeken würden seit zweieinhalb jahren
vom hessischen arbeitsmarkt
ausgeschlossen heisst dass ein junger
usbeke findet hier keine stelle mehr
nein richtige stellen gibt es keine mehr
vielleicht als billig hilfskraft auf dem
markt da verdienst 100 sommertag
wundersam das sind umgerechnet rund 2
franken der kritischen start stand
bislang auffallend abseits
es sind vor allem internationale
hilfswerk reichen die kritischen usbeken
in den letzten monaten unterstützt haben
noch muss der ungedeckte hof als
gemeinschaftsküche dienen
es stimmt traurig mit anzusehen wie die
familie des einstigen konditormeisters
sadiqov hier ums überleben kämpft
sehr zurückhaltend trauen sich die
usbeken von roche ihre quartiere zu
verlassen noch werk der schock juni 2010
nach
man zeigt meerwasser letzten monaten
wieder aufgebaut werden konnte
die schlafräume wir stehen ihnen
teilweise wiederaufgebauten wohnhaus
seinen arbeitsplatz aber april kommt
schon sadiqov verloren
was ist damals geschehen
wir sind zuerst alle in den keller
geflüchtet
dann haben wir uns auf den benachbarten
dachboden zurückgezogen
die kinder sind dann zum teil aufs dach
geflüchtet
von dort mussten wir sie runter zwingen
[Musik]
am zweiten tag der pogrome sind wir weg
auf die felder geflüchtet und haben dort
drei bis vier tage verbracht
dann sind wir wieder zurückgekehrt l und
john steed of führt mich zu den
überbleibseln seiner konditorei das ist
alles was von seinem rühe wert übrig
geblieben ist seine ganze schokoladen
strecke die ganze bank stube zerstört
nur ein foto ist übrig geblieben
hier in diesem raum haben sie auch
früher gelebt ja und was ist ihnen nach
dem brand geblieben
nichts ist uns geblieben nicht nur ein
kleid nur ein kleiner fisch retten
können doch der überlebenswille ist
beeindruckend
hier bauen vater und sohn und im einsatz
einfachste hilfsmittel eine neue
außentreppe in einer schattigen ecke des
innenhofs wird das mittagessen
aufgetischt
ob es jemals wieder zu einem guten
einvernehmen zwischen den kassen und den
pazifischen usbeken kommen wird ist
ungewiss
in unserem nächsten folge nehmen wir sie
mit wenn wir uns hoch zu ross der
chinesischen grenzen her und in
chinesische kaschgar auf den großen
viehmarkt
und wir sind am südrand der packer makan
wüste zu besuch bei al gore ischen
zeigen weber
[Musik]
[Applaus]